[تصفيق]
امواج الاحتجاجات الايرانيه تتجاوز حاجز
الخوف منذ عام
1999 وصولا للعام الحالي ست موجات
احتجاجيه وبين كل موجه واخرى يتشكلوا
وعيون وادراك لما يطمح اليه الايرانيون
اما النظام فتبقى الياته واحده في مواجهه
تطلعات الشعب الايراني ومطالبه الاخذ في
التغيير والتطور
[تصفيق]
مشهد الاحتجاجات هذه المره يختلف كليا عن
ما كانت عليه سابقا احتجاجات تمتلك رمزا
لتفه حوله الايرانيون وعلى نقيض
الاحتجاجات السابقه المهدده بتراجع
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه والمعيشيه يطالب
المحتاجون بالحق في الحياه والحريه بعد
مقتل ماسا مني على يد شرطه الاخلاق
[موسيقى]
ومن اختلاف لاخر بظهور الانتفاضه الشعبيه
الايرانيه معبره عن الاقليات وعبره الحدود
الارقيات وخلافاتها
الاكراد والاحوازيين والبنوش في المحافظات
الحدوديه ينتفضون وامام البلوش في ايران
يؤيده تفاه المحتجين المطالبه بتغيير
جذريه
الشعب الذي يتظاهر منذ 50 يوما في الشوارع
لن تستطيع ارغامه على التراجع عبر القتل
والاعتقالات ادعوا الى استفتاء عام برعايه
اماميه
[موسيقى]
الانتفاضه الايرانيه تاتي في ظل مستقبل
سياسيا ضبابي للنظام خلافه غير واضحه
للمرشد الاعلى علي خامنئي في ظل تقارير
تشير الى تراجع
الصحيح للتيارات المعتدله ما دفع رئيس
البرلماني الايراني
للخروج عن صمته
لابد من الاعتراف بان الاحتجاجات لها جذور
سياسيه عميقه وليست مجرد نتيجه لحراك
امريكي او اسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
كلما زادت حده الاحتجاجات زادت معها
الفجوه بين النظام والمتظاهرين بمختلف
اطيافهم طلاب الجامعات والمدارس شباب
وفتيات ينضم اليهم شخصيات فنيه وثقافيه
ايرانيه تواجه حمله اعتقالات واسعه
لتلقى الانتفاضه تضامنا دوليا طالما طالبت
باستعادته هويه البلاد على السمان العربيه